alors c'est pollen aujourd'hui alors
tous les sujets que vous avez fait
m'intéressent énormément et aujourd'hui
encore plus que en plus elle va vous
poser des questions Ségolène Royal parce
que on entend parler que de ça et on y
comprend plus rien comment est fixé le
prix du carburant moi je ne comprends
rien donc expliquer moi Ségolène et je
peux alors je suis peut-être le seul il
y a beaucoup de gens qui nous regardent
mais on a envie de comprendre alors
d'abord est-ce que quelqu'un se souvient
du prix de l'essence et du gazole au
moment de la révolte des gilets jaunes à
40 ouais c'est ça
donc oui à ce moment là il y a une
révolte parce qu'il y a une taxe carbone
et que le prix de l'essence et du gazole
allait augmenter et aujourd'hui nous en
sommes à 2 euros alors le premier
tableau c'est pour vous expliquer que la
moitié du prix de l'essence la moitié ce
sont des impôts la moitié c'est à dire
quand vous allez à la pompe que vous
payez 2 euros il y a 1 euro qui passe en
taxe et impôts donc ce qui n'est pas
normal c'est que quand vous payez un
litre 2 euros il y a 1 euro d'impôt mais
quand c'était un 40 vous payez la moitié
70 centimes exactement donc le
gouvernement l'ancre ministère des
Finances disons pour neutraliser
augmente l'impôt au fur et à mesure ou
le prix du pétrole augmente donc on
pourrait tout de suite baisser je l'ai
appris tout de suite en baissant de si
on dit il va que le prix normal de
l'essence et du gazole c'est un 40 à 50
on laisse parfois quel bon mathématicien
70 centimes donc on baisse tout de suite
de 30 centimes ça c'est ça ça fait un
litre à 1 euro 70 ce qui devrait pas
augmenter au dessus et même qui devrait
baisser au fur et à mesure où les autres
parties de
qui constitue le prix de l'essence
peuvent baisser ça c'est la première
observation deuxième est-ce que vous
connaissez les différentes étapes de
fabrication de l'essence la première
étape c'est drôle
ensuite vous avez transport le transport
ensuite vous avez la distribution et la
pompe donc qu'est-ce qui se passe on va
regarder le second tableau l'extraction
donc si on a lancé son dans les pays
j'en profite pour dire c'est dans les
pays producteurs de pétrole il y a 13
pays producteurs de pétrole dans une
organisation qu'on appelle l'OPEP et ce
prix est fixé par un système boursier
c'est l'offre et la demande donc quand
les pays producteurs diminuent la
production pour faire monter le prix ça
fait monter le prix quand ils augmentent
la production
au contraire ça fait baisser un peu le
prix mais ça varie assez peu c'est à
dire que alors ça c'est pas le bon
graphique voilà c'est celui-là le
précédent voilà regardez ça c'est une
variation des différents prix du ce
qu'on appelle le brut le pétrole avec
les différentes composantes oui ça varie
en fait assez peu il y a des piques il y
a des etc et le graphique suivant ce
sont les marges des raffineurs vous
allez voir vous avez vu que même quand
le pétrole baisse les regarder les pics
de marche des raffineurs ils s'en
mettent c'est des profiteurs de crise
ben parce que c'est aussi sur un marché
boursier qui est à Rotterdam et qui fixe
le prix là aussi en fonction de la
spéculation donc il suffirait que les
organisations internationales et que les
pays globalement disent bah non le prix
du raffinage qu'est-ce que c'est que le
raffinage d'ailleurs elle a
transformation du pétrole en faisant
quoi en essence oui en faisant quoi
faisons quoi
[Rires]
du bruit dans le jardin
pour en faire de l'essence
on fait chauffer et après il y a donc il
y a des produits plus ou moins raffinés
qui sont belles donc c'est un processus
industriel si vous voulez avec un bien
précis donc il suffirait de dire ben non
le raffinage c'est un processus
industriel avec un coût bien précis le
prix doit être fixé en fonction du coût
de fabrication finalement de ce
raffinage au lieu de délivrer la
spéculation donc là on pourrait aussi
réglementer et réguler le prix du
pétrole pour montrer qu'il y a des
solutions pour baisser le c'est ça c'est
à dire il faudrait penser autrement
l'organisme avec les différents
producteurs donc en ce moment il y a
deux anomalies c'est-à-dire quand le
prix on vient de voir les graphiques
quand le prix du pétrole monte le prix
du raffinage monte aussi parce que c'est
en pourcentage chacun se sert et quand
le prix du pétrole baisse le prix du
raffinage monte aussi parce qu'ils
prennent la différence ils se disent pas
vu pas pris on prend la différence c'est
ce qu'on appelle les surprofis et c'est
ce qu'on appelle aussi les profiteurs de
crise donc on pourrait très bien
réglementer ces marges réglementer ses
prix faire la transparence sur le coup
du raffinage et laisser la rémunération
le juste bénéfice par rapport à cette
activité de raffinage le transport alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé sur le
transport vous avez entendu que les le
prix du transport a explosé notamment
pendant le covid puisqu'il y avait donc
là aussi profiteur de crise le prix du
transport maritime a été multiplié par
le coup les salaires et tout ça du
transport maritime n'a pas été multiplié
par 12 donc là aussi on pourrait très
bien dire non le prix du transport
maritime ou alors ce que ça coûte voilà
ce que ça vaut voilà quel est le juste
bénéfice des entreprises il n'y a aucune
raison qui est des profitures de crise
sur le transport maritime ensuite il y a
la distribution donc il y a trois
réseaux de distribution lesquels les
grands raffineurs
BP etc oui qui prennent les marges eux
sur toute la ligne que total il prend
les marches sur toute la ligne
extracteur raffineur etc c'est pour ça
que sont les seuls à proposer un 99 oui
et encore ils font déjà des supers
profits avec ça puisqu'ils ils ont déjà
fait des profits sur toutes les étapes
de la distribution du raffinage du
transport etc soit les grandes surfaces
commerciales mais elle elle se rattrape
aussi parce que ça leur amène des
clients et puis de toute façon elles
font aussi le profil ça n'existe pas le
prix coûtant c'est que forcément on fait
elles font du bénéfice quand même soit
les pompiers sont indépendants eux on
leur dit vous allez voir à perdre
maintenant eux ils gagnent 1 centime à 1
centimètre par litre donc voilà
pour conclure vous voyez que ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que c'est une
filière spéculative et qui est sans
règles et qu'il irait la possibilité de
mettre des règles dans les organisations
internationales puisque plus le pétrole
augmente plus les marges des
intermédiaires augmentent et quand le
pétrole baisse
l'essence ne baisse pas donc voyez il y
a une anomalie vous avez remarqué
d'ailleurs parfois en annonce la hausse
du prix du pétrole bouffe tout de suite
ça monte à la pompe on annonce la baisse
du prix du pétrole là on attend trois
semaines quatre semaines et puis et puis
ça baisse beaucoup moins que
proportionnellement voilà donc j'avais
compris vous avez des questions avec
l'inflation juste pour terminer avec
l'inflation comme la TVA est en
pourcentage avec l'inflation il y a eu
40 nous avons payé 40 milliards d'impôts
supplémentaires vous voyez on nous dit
il y a pas les impôts n'augmente pas si
parce que dès que les prix augmentent
comme la TVA est en contact et puis ça
tout le monde paye les moyens les
pauvres les riches la peau en plus le
plus injuste au moment même où l'impôt
sur les grandes fortunes financières a
été supprimée donc là aussi il y a des
marges de manœuvre à la fois de justice
et d'efficacité est-ce qu'il y a des
questions alors attendez est-ce que je
réponds vraiment il y aura une interro
ministre
l'État prend quand même beaucoup
d'argent et que le l'impôt c'est de
manière proportionnelle pourquoi au lieu
de donner des chèques anecdotique l'État
ne baisse pas tout de suite l'info sur
l'essence pour ça exactement c'est une
présente 8 euros par mois pour les
Français c'est rien c'est une très bonne
question c'est dire là il faudrait faire
une gestion baisser le prix de l'essence
de 30 centimes c'est ce que viennent de
faire là d'ailleurs les Allemands et les
Espagnols ils ont baissé de 30 centimes
pour tout le monde le prix de l'essence
bien sûr
que le gouvernement apparaît moins cher
et puis c'est la visible parce que
regardez pour les gilets jaunes se sont
révoltés alors que l'impôt l'essence
était un 50 parce qu'il y avait une taxe
mais en fait c'est pire ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui mais comme il y a pas
d'annonce de taxes et que c'est beaucoup
plus insidieux puisque ces
proportionnelle et c'est à la pompe et
qu'on voit pas qu'il y a une taxe
décidé en tant que tel c'est beaucoup
plus insidieux donc les gens subissent
ça alors qu'il y a d'autres solutions
c'est ça qui est important
j'ai une question
on est à 2 euros mais rien n'indique les
prix vont arrêter de grimper c'est ça
les perspectives on est d'accord sont à
la hausse alors aujourd'hui par exemple
le prix du pétrole a un peu baissé donc
ça c'est un peu stabilisé donc les pays
producteurs aussi n'ont pas forcément
intérêt à faire non plus à déclencher
des crises dans le monde entier mais
cela dit effectivement c'est la raison
pour laquelle pour répondre à votre
question et il serait il est urgent de
réglementer l'ensemble des étapes
puisqu'on peut récupérer des baisses de
prix sur la spéculation des raffineurs
on peut récupérer des baisses de prix
sur le transport on peut récupérer des
baisses de prix en stabilisant l'impôt
et sans le laisser augmenter donc vous
voyez une marge de manœuvre moi je pense
que le prix de l'essence devrait revenir
à 1 euro 50 je devrais pas être plus
d'un euro
justement moi je me demandais pourquoi
est-ce que l'État ne pourrait pas
pour calmer le peuple mettre une loi en
place de transparence
qui montrerait tout simplement la bonne
foi de chacun
la transparent la démocratie c'est la
transparence
par exemple à bloquer tout un pays
tellement longtemps alors tu parles le
monde suffisait de mettre en place cette
loi là pour bien prouver que il y a de
la bonne fois partout et après les
gilets jaunes c'était réglé au final oui
il fallait surtout retirer la taxe
carbone qu'il avait qui en plus c'était
justifié soi-disant par l'écologie alors
c'était plus pire que tout elle a fini
par être retirée d'ailleurs la taxe
carbone oui présent
le seul problème c'est si on descend les
taxes sur la sur le pétrole donc pour
faire baisser le prix ça va faire un
manque à gagner pour l'État donc où ça
se répercute sur les autres impôts ou
alors on creuse encore la dette publique
et déjà énorme BIM
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on se calme je l'ai je vais retourner le
raisonnement en disant que le fait ça
n'est pas de ne pas augmenter le fait
c'est de ne pas augmenter c'est de ne
pas prendre plus quand le sens d'un euro
50 il y a 70 centimes d'impôts il y a
aucune raison parce que le prix du brut
augmente que l'impôt augmente donc
l'idée c'est de ne pas c'est de ne pas
prendre plus c'est de prendre la même
sommeil
il y a d'autres questions encore des
questions
monsieur Montiel bonsoir bonsoir vous
avez
évoqué tout à l'heure qui va à l'état
est-ce que vous savez à quoi il sert
cette roue il rentre dans le budget de
l'État oui mais c'est comme ça les
écoles c'est les rouges
et ça tout le monde les gens qui ont
besoin de prendre leur voiture pour
aller travailler c'est pas normal vous
voulez que les petits les moyens les
gros les gros les très gros revenus
payent la même chose alors que
parallèlement été supprimé l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune financière
aussi parce que du coup ils réduisent
leur production pour justement faire
monter les prix oui comme vous l'avez
dit c'est l'offre et la demande et ça
c'est un vrai problème parce que du coup
par exemple l'Arabie Saoudite ou le
Qatar et lequel soi-disant de très bons
rapports ils ont réduit leur
consommation pour leur production pour
justement faire monter les prix
alors est-ce que vous connaissez quels
sont les grands pays producteurs de
pétrole pour terminer qui est le premier
pays qui est le premier pays producteur
non les États-Unis
ils font du gaz de schiste et tout et
voilà ensuite l'Arabie Saoudite
Russie ensuite
[Musique]
la Chine la Chine l'Irak les Émirats
arabes unis l'Iran voilà il y a 13 pays
producteurs de pétrole et c'est vrai
avec certains qui dominent complètement
le marché
aux États-Unis il devrait aussi faire un
effort pour réguler quand même le prix
du pétrole parce qu'avec en plus avec la
guerre en Ukraine ça a pas forcément
obligé aux États-Unis
mesure tout de suite c'est quoi tout de
suite je baisse l'impôt tout de suite
déjà je régule les marges des raffineurs
deuxièmement et puis la troisième je
régule le prix du transport maritime et
ça on le verrait tout de suite c'est à
dire qu'on a un mois oui je pense que on
négocie aussi avec les autres pays qui
sont d'accords
c'est aussi des choix c'est des choix
c'est à dire certains pensent que il
faut tout confier au marché à la loi de
l'offre et de la demande et on voit plus
sur le raffinage c'est quand même une
aberration parce que c'est une procédure
un produit une procédé un prose
industrielle qui a son coup précis donc
on pourrait parfaitement calculer
stabiliser le coût du raffinage et ne
pas le laisser à la spéculation et donc
après c'est des choix pour peser
effectivement sur l'organisation du
monde dans le contexte de mondialisation
de l'économie il faut reprendre la main
sur la réglementation d'un certain
nombre de choses pour protéger les
citoyens à bout
Bernard dites moyen de pression il y a
pas de moyens de pression parce que
c'est pour revenir à ce que dit c'est
golem en ce que dit Madame Ségolène
Royal en 2008
qui était à 90 dollars il y a 10 15 ans
ont payé 130 c'est que des taxes qui ont
été inventés donc tu dis moyen de
pression c'est des taxes quand tu as
inventé tu ferais juste de geler
certaines taxes comme la taxe carbone de
dire ça on met on fait l'impasse dessus
pendant qu'on est dans ce conflit avec
l'Ukraine pendant qu'on est englué dans
dans ce de 2 euros on revient à 40 à 50
et on verra après pour la taxe carbone
c'est pas parce qu'on va arrêter 6 mois
la taxe carbone on va sauver l'univers
on pourrait jeûner peut-être ça le temps
parce que 90 dollars il y a 10 ans le
pétrole à 90 dollars c'est un 30 à la
pompe regardez sur internet
tu voulais dire en vrai parce que tu
avais levé la main avant qu'il ait ça
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire en vrai
c'était juste de dire qu'avant c'était
possible puisque quand le baril il a 90
dollars on peut faire de l'essence à 130
pourquoi aujourd'hui le baril à 90
dollars on fait de l'essence à 2 euros
c'est la spéculation sur le processus
quand ça monte ça ne baisse pas à la
pompe alors je sais pas si vous avez
répondu ou si j'ai pas si j'ai eu un
moment de d'inattention
vu qu'elle a mondialisation et donc au
niveau des coûts on pourrait pouvoir
réguler ça pourquoi le prix de l'essence
est différent dans les dans chaque pays
au final s'annule d'abord parce que la
fiscalité est différente il y en a qui
prennent moins d'impôts ensuite parce
qu'il y en a qui sont producteurs de
pétrole donc pour eux non mais je parle
des pays par exemple limitrophes de
France qui n'ont rien à voir avec c'est
essentiellement la fiscalité
en Allemagne c'est différent et puis
après il y a les réseaux
d'approvisionnement qui sont parfois
différents
par exemple l'Allemagne achète du
pétrole en Inde et le négocier
mieux effectivement
voilà qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
chèque de 100 euros qui a été mis en
place par le gouvernement pour les
Français qui représentent donc 8 euros
par mois est-ce que vous trouvez pas que
c'est méprisant et insultant pour les
Français parce que 8 euros par mois on
fait rien avec c'est ce que vous
l'auriez fait vous non à l'année enfin
je veux dire c'est c'est choquant même
12 millions de Français
[Rires]
pour l'essence c'est d'autant plus
incompréhensible qu'on avait déjà eu la
révolte des gilets jaunes il y avait
conduit au retrait d'attaque des chèques
de descente qui avait pas de voiture ça
veut dire qu'ils ont fait des arrêts
pas de voiture
il a raison il y a même eu un bruit oui
c'est vrai il y a des mecs qui ont eu
100 € d'essence alors il y a pas de
voiture
vous parlez de profiteur de crise vous
avez employé le terme si c'était si
facile pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne tape pas
sur ces profiteurs de crise le transport
maritime les grands raffineurs en plus
ce serait populaire de la part du
gouvernement si on ne le fait pas une
raison et oui c'est un choix idéologique
de se dire non on n'intervient pas dans
l'économie on laisse fonctionner la loi
de l'offre et de la demande on laisse la
spéculation on taxe pas les super
profits etc c'est est-ce que c'est un
choix une incapacité de le faire plus
exactement je pense qu'il y a toujours
oui c'est une bonne question
je pense que la politique c'est toujours
la morale de l'action c'est toujours
pensé qu'on peut modifier le cours des
choses et défendre l'intérêt général par
rapport aux intérêts particuliers qui
ont aussi leur légitimité mais carrément
il faut réguler il faut mettre des
règles il faut expliquer aux gens de
quoi il retourne parce que du coup si
tout était expliqué l'opinion exigerait
peut-être des décisions plus de bon sens
et plus efficace que vous voulez vous
madame vous taperiez sur total est-ce
qu'on ne le fait pas le gouvernement ne
le fait pas vous contrarier total je
vais vous dire je ferai payer un total
au moins des impôts en France parce que
Total ne paye zéro
et c'est quand même très choquant parce
que quand on a des autorisations de
forage en tel ou tel pays c'est quand
même la diplomatie française aussi quand
total bénéficie de l'image de marque de
la France aussi quand total adala
distribution de naissance en France de
pays des impôts je vais vous dire ce qui
est encore plus choquant ils vont pas
être contents total ah ça c'est que non
seulement il paye pas d'impôts mais là
ils viennent d'obtenir une subvention
publique c'est-à-dire payée par nos
impôts de 5 millions d'euros pour faire
leur raffinerie au Havre non quand j'ai
vu ça j'ai mais c'est quand même pas
c'est pas possible donc il y a ceux
quand même qui ont du pouvoir et qui ça
incroyable
c'était par rapport à ses chèques
effectivement qui sont c'est rien du
tout on ne vous a pas demandé votre avis
défendre il va défendre vous voulez je
pose une question bah oui c'est c'est
curieux donc c'est qu'il y avait des
chats qui étaient prévus pour à peu près
12 millions de personnes il y en a que
quatre et demi qui ont été les récupérer
ces chèques de 100 euros
d'électricité d'énergie il y a des
chèques énergie les gens ne sont pas
encore récupéré pas non au lieu que
c'est directement alors que tout est
dématérialisé aujourd'hui oui mais bon
facture vous pourriez mettre sur la
facture des matérialisée elle Aristote
là on est obligé les gens à trouver une
enveloppe un timbre avoir une boîte aux
lettres envoyer un courrier à recevoir
le courrier à renvoyer le chèque à
l'heure au tout début des matérialisé
mais quand c'est pour nous c'est exprès
pour que les gens demandent pas
leur chèque en fait c'est vrai la carte
une prochaine fois si on fait le prix de
l'électricité parce que ça vous
intéresse
je sais plus qu'est-ce qu'un baril
qu'est-ce qu'un baril un baril de brut
on entend souvent parler de baril de
pétrole qu'est-ce qu'un barillet
est-ce que le baril
[Applaudissements]
s alors c'est tout simple c'est le
critère de mesure pour le tissu on prend
un mètre pour le pétrole c'est le baril
historique et c'est 159 oui je ne trouve
pas 159 litres le baril donc la cotation
du baril quand vous entendez ça en fait
c'est juste une mesure un critère de
mesure d'une quantité de pétrole merci
je voudrais qu'on la police très fort
[Applaudissements]